Speaker 1: Really good piece in The Guardian
by our friend and former guest on this program,
Jason Stanley, about the so-called culture
war that seeks to ban ideas in banned books
and remove entire subject matter from an advanced
placement Black History course in Florida
and say these books shouldn't be here, that
those books should be there.
And Jason very eloquently explains in this
article titled Banning Ideas and Authors is
not a culture war, it's fascism.
A lot of the important elements of this and
he says it much more eloquently than I could.
So I encourage you to read the article, which
we're going to link to and the description
to the YouTube video for this story.
But I want to build on this in some way and
tell you some of the ways in which this sort
of ideology has gone very poorly in the past
and agree with Jason that we really can't
when we say this is part of the culture war.
Some people want to ban books and some don't.
This is part of the culture war.
Some people want to remove the teaching of
certain lessons from school curricula and
some want to.
It's just a culture war, just a disagreement.
It is critical that we see it as a form of
fascism.
And when you look at history, when you look
at regimes that have tried or did ban or burned
books, silence, dissenting voices, it has
frequently ended in tragedy or led to absolutely
horrible circumstances.
You have to look at Nazi Germany.
The burning of books was a tactic used to
suppress opposition and impose, I guess we
would call it like ideological conformity.
You will conform the Nazis.
New books could be powerful tools for challenging
their worldview.
So they set out to destroy those books and
materials that didn't fit with their narrative.
The Soviet Union, where the government maintained
really strict control over what people could
read and write.
Dissenting voices were silenced.
Anyone who spoke out could be labeled a traitor
or punished extraordinarily severely.
In the United States, we've seen attempts
to ban books.
We've seen attempts to censor ideas throughout
history.
You go to the McCarthy era, we have these
more recent attempts around critical race
theory.
The efforts are always about maintaining power,
controlling the narrative and suppressing
dissenting ideas and voices.
Now, this is a really important distinction.
When we talk about Orwellian versus Huxley
in OC, often things are called Orwellian in
modern society when really modern American
culture is more Huxley and this book banning
is actually more Orwellian.
So let me explain this a little bit, and if
this is interesting to you, it's been widely
written about an explored when we talk about
Huxley and we're talking about Aldous Huxley's
book Brave New World, we're talking about
a society that is kind of kept passive and
under control, not through force and oppression
and the banning of books, but through pleasure
and distraction and entertainment.
And that is mostly what we have when we look.
I mean, Fox News is the perfect example of
Huxley and Fox News mixes opinion and news.
So you can't tell which it is they.
It's the fire hood, a fire hose of falsehood.
There's just tons of stuff being pumped out
so you don't even know what's real and what's
not.
Fox News and right wing media match real news
reporting with disinformation to the point
where the average person sometimes is unclear,
which is the news and which is the made up
stuff.
And it encourages people to be apathetic,
to be superficial in their understanding of
what's going on in the world and to value
entertainment.
If the news doesn't entertain me, then I'm
probably not watching.
That's not Orwellian.
Most of what we have in modern American culture
is actually Huxley, and it's you don't need
to do the Orwellian stuff because people are
just going to pay attention to what's entertaining.
They can't really tell the difference.
They're apathetic anyway.
Okay.
When we talk about the book banning, we are
actually talking about something that is more
Orwellian, where society is controlled through
oppression and surveillance and control, and
in a Huxley in society, information and ideas
are controlled and manipulated through culture
and entertainment, and you can push ideas
out or replace them with things that are more
titillating or whatever the case may be.
The book banning efforts are much more Orwellian
because they are a direct attempt to suppress
ideas in information.
It's using government censorship in the case
of Florida.
It's the idea of the state government wanting
to change or control what is in the curriculum
for that Black History course.
Often times it's powerful interest groups
that are controlling or whatever the case
may be.
It's a much more direct form of control Orwellian.
Most of American society is Huxley, and the
book banning efforts should be seen as forms
of fascism, and they actually are Orwellian.
We'll have more about this discussion on our
Instagram, so make sure you are following
us there.
You can search David Pakman show on Instagram.